[Music]
[Music]
hey folks
brett here welcome to this unity 2020
public service announcement as those who
have been following us know we are
running
our vote today to figure out which
ticket to draft
we have unveiled a new system for voting
and
as is often the case with new systems we
did run into a hiccup
some of you were able to vote others ran
into
difficulty so what we are doing
is we have fixed the flaw in the system
and if you were able to vote earlier
today you don't need to do anything
if you ran into trouble what we need you
to do is check your email you will find
new instructions we are extending the
voting period
through midnight tonight eastern time in
the u.s
so find that email if you don't see it
there's a good chance it's in your spam
filter you can find it there follow the
directions
and vote i will say at a personal level
i found the experience of doing a rank
choice vote
very liberating i hadn't thought about
it before but
just even the fact of being able to rank
the choices rather than select one
made a heck of a lot more sense than the
usual kind of voting we face in the u.s
so
there's something in that all right if
you have any trouble
if you can't find the email or you run
into any other difficulty you can
email help at unityvote.org and we will
get you the help
you need again make sure that you have
voted by
midnight eastern time today
okay other announcements tomorrow we
will have the results of today's vote
that is the rank order
and we will present them to you in a 6
p.m
pacific time campfire now i myself will
not be present for that i'm having some
dental surgery tomorrow and so will
likely be drooling on myself at that
point
but we will have one of our amazing
volunteer patriots there to present
those results and discuss them
with you uh also you should pay
attention
because we are soon to unveil our ballot
access plan and there's of course been a
lot of discussion about whether we even
have a ballot access plan lots of people
seem to be betting against that but of
course there is a plan and we are going
to reveal it to you
later this week so stay tuned if you are
not signed up at our
uh at our website please go to
articlesofunity.org
and give us your email address
we will also have a campfire this
wednesday i will be present for that
with a special guest
that should be uh excellent and on the
final
final point um the articles of
unity twitter account is still suspended
by twitter without a proper explanation
now we have nearly completed an internal
audit of our organization to make sure
we are not guilty of the things that
they are accusing us of but in any case
it would seem that twitter
has at the very least engaged in a wild
overreaction to something
if not something worse than that so i
would ask you to please be prepared
after our audit is done to make some
noise if twitter will not release our
account something is very seriously
wrong and
and it needs to be countered so we could
certainly use your help getting their
attention
all right that's it for me tonight uh we
will see you tomorrow
at 6 p.m to reveal the rank choice of
our
various tickets as a result of today's
vote we will see you wednesday
for a special campfire
and we will announce the ballot access
plan later this week all right
thanks for me and i'll see you later
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
you